if i understand you correctly
saving the world from a christian
perspective
is into the footsteps of
jesus
to be just and to do good
and
but then some do some don't yeah that's
but
this is
you know look one of them not only this
okay but this you asked me for the
question of religion when i reply
but i think that we need today
to follow
faith and reason
and not only philosophical reason but
also scientific reason and put together
in a real dialogue these things
like do
pope francis in laudato si
that
describe the situation of the world
especially the question on climate
change
and
put this in relation of our tasks in the
world
that come from the scriptures that we
are the distinguished
of the earth there
we don't say creation because too much
but there
and and for this we need
faith
reason
philosophication values moral reason and
scientific reason
so in understanding how we change the
world in order to achieve goals that we
can defend and i agree there can be but
there isn't necessarily overlap between
the goals of say secular humanism and a
religious worldview but to the extent
that we
agree if we agree that those goals are
human flourishing namely life health
education happiness richness of
experience then how we
maximize those is going to very much
depend on our understanding of what
causes what in the world and our
understanding of what causes what in the
world
comes from science by definition because
that's what science is in the business
of doing namely understanding the world
with the unders with the method that
none of us is omniscient that we cannot
understand the world by
revelation by faith by dogma by sacred
texts but rather by
proposing hypotheses and seeing
letting the world tell us whether they
are true or false
the fact that we
can see ways in which we've improved the
world by the application of knowledge
emboldens us to think that we can
improve it uh still further
but but
[Applause]
you could be this part
for the visible war i completely agree
but they are another part of the world
that we can say invisible war
that is not enough science
we need for this
for the great meanings we need
something that comes from revelation
why should we believe revelation
or revelation to to put in relation with
faith
revelation with
that is to say some new intervention
in the world that is not
the only declaration
that is a new intervention of god
in the world
but if it's revelation it has not been
revealed to me maybe it's been revealed
to you
what are you going to do about the fact
that there are people like me people in
this audience people in the world who
have not seen the same revelation that
you may have seen
who
have no plans to accept jesus as our
savior i'm a jew i'm i'm going to tell
you i'm not going to accept jesus sorry
i don't think i'm i don't think i'm
that's a big problem in terms of making
the world a better place
i don't think that the billions of
people who have not and will not accept
jesus i don't think that's the world's
problem
they have not
experienced the same revelation perhaps
that you have i don't think that's the
problem either because we don't need
revelation if we can appeal to
dimensions of experience that are
available to everyone
such as evidence such as reason such as
a concern with human flourishing maybe
this argument is going to lead us back
again
why we couldn't save the world with
religion with knowledge with technology
with politics with the human activists
with the human rights what went wrong
50 years 70 years everybody has been
debating how we can create a better
world how we can create a better
humanity how we the dialogue between
religion the dialogue between different
groups that they're logged between
nations
well i get back to my argument because
for me as a libyan who have spent
50 years of my life
trying to save the world honestly
speaking today i will be sharing with
you how i can save libya in order for me
to be able to save the world and syria
and what's happening in our region so
this is how we can change the world we
need courage we need honesty we need to
to revisit our thinking and religion
and and now this whole game of religion
religion politics intellectual it's not
that blaming anybody is all connected
it's all related this now war of islam i
am a muslim woman but a muslim woman of
a 21st century
i thank my father when i was five years
old he sent me to the church in tripoli
to a catholic church my best friends
were jews and we were playing together
this whole business this whole political
business that's taking place in our
region has nothing to do with with
religion
this islamophobia that you are afraid
from
it is really all money
oil business
political interests so i think
if we want to save this world if we want
to have a better world
we need now to really rethink we need to
apologize to the new generation that we
screwed it up we need to learn from the
mistakes of the past we need to build
on whatever good deeds we have and we
need
to connect the good people because the
evils are connected and there are many
good people in this world that they need
to be connected and you need the north
has to respect the south the men have to
respect the women the rich have to
respect the poor the elderly have to
believe in children and now i'm only
working with children and with youth i
can no longer i reach 70 years old i can
no longer have the patience to continue
with all these intellectuals you know
the american administrations
the american the american the last
american election proved to us that the
media is a big joke
that the the
public opinion paul a big lie
that the think tank the think tanks have
been talking about our region that we
will never change and then when we had
the revolutions it was a big surprise so
i'm sorry i spoke too much but i'll come
back to you
in june 2015 a 20 year old white
supremacist killed in the church in
america
in south carolina reverend pikney and
his bible study group and president
obama
president obama gave an ideology
well i'm moved to tears by that i've
seen it many times it breaks my
heart not only for that scene
but for
the fact that this election is a
repudiation of president obama
our first african-american president a
great president
and
um i'm filled with a sense of
grief myself for my country i had never
seen this and i'm trembling
and it makes me realize that we are all
human
and it makes me hope
that all of us
will find the strength
and the humility to actually be human
[Applause]
[Music]
you